In this lecture,
we'll discuss how
analytics and, in
particular, optimization
is used in online dating.
Specifically, we'll discuss the
story of the company eHarmony
that uses optimization
to maximize
the probability of
a successful match
between compatible adults.
The goal of eHarmony is to
take a scientific approach
to love and marriage and
offer it to the masses
through an online
dating website focused
on long term relationships.
Indicators of
success for eHarmony
include the fact that nearly
4% of U.S. marriages in 2012
are a result of eHarmony.
Furthermore, the company
has generated, by 2009,
over $1 billion in revenue.
How is eHarmony different?
Unlike other online
dating websites,
eHarmony does not have users
browse other users' profiles.
Instead, eHarmony uses
a compatibility score
between two people and uses
optimization algorithms
to determine the
user's best matches.
How does eHarmony compute
the compatibility score?
The score is based on
29 different dimensions
of personality including
character, emotions, values,
traits, etc.
The calculation involves
a 436 questionnaire.
The matches must
meet at least 25
out of 29 compatibility areas.
The graph from eHarmony's
website shown in this slide
describes one such question
regarding character.
Let us discuss the
history of the company.
The founder of the company
is Dr. Neil Clark Warren,
a clinical psychologist who
counseled couples and began
to see that many marriages
ended in divorce because couples
were not initially compatible.
Warren has written many
relationship books.
Finding the Love of your
Life, The Triumphant Marriage,
Learning to Live with the Love
of Your Life and Loving It,
Finding Commitment,
and many others.
In the late 1990s,
after more than 35 years
of work as a clinical
psychologist and marriage
counselor, Warren decided
to test his theory
that certain characteristics can
predict compatibility and lead
to more satisfying
relationships.
After three years
of research Warren
developed a model
of compatibility
that is now the basis of the
company's matching system.
The service launched its
matching service for singles
in 2000.
Since then, the company has
had about 33 million members,
and as of 2008,
about 15,000 people
take the eHarmony
questionnaire each day.
Interested users may fill
out the compatibility quiz,
but in order to
see matches members
must pay a membership
fee to eHarmony.
What is a distinguishing
characteristic of eHarmony?
While eHarmony was not the
first online dating website
and faced serious
competition, there
is a key difference from
other dating websites.
eHarmony takes a quantitative
optimization approach
to matchmaking
rather than letting
users browse their website.
In this lecture,
we'll explore some
of the analytics eHarmony uses.